yeah welcome to this video playing
amazing grace from Germany let's let's
play the London for a change not the
Queens gambit all the time it's
certainly the the more ambitious opening
but yeah some variety can hurt yeah I
think one idea here is to take mr.
supposition that there are positions
where you can take okay let's try this
obviously if you can't take isn't it
this is not the problem but I mean take
with some sort of IDM the idea here is a
plane I'd be five
who came how to proceed quinta foreign
think
one idea of this is that if black
captures I take with the upon its it's
quite quite nice for white and here ok I
get the bishops you can hardly move the
king and give away be seven so we get
this position we have the bishops but
I'm a bit a bit underdeveloped but it's
not so so problematic this Bishop is is
a nice piece yeah this is a quite a
comfortable position Wow good move good
move yeah he wants to play something to
be five but should be five most likely
okay push this back to f6
hmm ok this is a bit artificial I hope
it sound it's okay the ideas of the
place we should be five a place he for
him yes it's a big part but his lights
are not very well positioned to exploit
that I hope to have concrete plane he
doesn't really have any direct way to
attack it
yet the night is certainly nice on the
phone
interesting yeah I understand that he
didn't like the idea to to exchange it
or let it been taken on c6 still a
bishop a foreign looks a bit weird
putting it on the edge of the board then
maybe it was necessary to possible so
hmm yeah might be five is a very direct
move but i want i want my pieces in play
especially this rook should participate
King f2 just king of to e5 not be huh
he's got rock detune which is quite them
quite annoying I should play this I
think I'm controlling d2 with the King
so I shouldn't play King f-22 quickly
and T I think he needs to take I don't
think 96 can be allowed and now
threatening b6 okay rook b3 was my idea
controlling c3 and to covering III yeah
this is two bishops against two nights
you need to get something really quickly
otherwise the bishops wipe them out but
he has some some squares yeah I know I
give you 85 but i get d 6 this is not a
bad place for the bishop
and maybe this is too closed
hmm
and what the heck did I do wrong now
hey this isn't this isn't great at all
and yeah probably five was bad so
difficult decision to make and probably
else i played this bad lame
it has been far too much time in the
process
they can take you to okay ah yeah if I
was was really bad probably problem I
mean blackest is sorry I'm completely
busted here this is to two bishops
against two nights it's just a loss in
this kind of stuff is the scanner
position I only need to play precisely
and not allowed too much blame and
allowed I allowed too much play just
what the key is to find to find a setup
where he cannot get active the other
compounds to play king of 285 is really
bad yeah that is bad I mean I thought
that Bishop d6 wood would be it would be
strong but it's not doing so much and
the the square d 5 is really am yeah
it's really it's really helping like
King f2 is the computer suggestion don't
like it because I've looked you too but
then it gives white 1.5 which doesn't
surprise me but look Tito what are you
playing on this I will see one
gap that is a bad position what can you
do something like this black takes the
sufficient e6 this is actually one one
key point we can he must always watch
bishop d 6 cm and here if he plays a
slow move like this for example this
even this exchange just one look off is
a it's quite terrible look you just look
at this something like this I just got
not be 50 K work somewhere I don't know
not King III this is they cannot move
and I'm I'm I'm intending attending this
yeah this is how you need to play the
key I absolutely cannot move the eeprom
this was just bad it looks nice there
but it doesn't do anything yeah and now
he's got here came physics is still not
good but the d5 night until it's it's
probably around equal but I completely
lost the thread him also by sort of
asking myself why am I not better yeah
if I was really a lemon this gets tricky
now it's hard to defend the pawns yeah
now that you fall upon it it just kills
both nights yeah bad positioning with me
five yeah I hope it was instructive I
mean this is really instructive you you
I mean I was aware to give up the square
it's not like I overlooked that but I
completely misjudged the distribution of
squares I thought bishop d6 wood would
be good but it's it's simply pointing
into into thin air the bishop is not
taking anything yeah afterwards it's
pretty obvious but when you play alright
thanks for watching